we begin this hour with one of the
biggest hip-hop artists in the game meek
mill who is celebrating a huge step
forward in his fight to reform the
criminal justice system a law that he
and his organization the reform alliance
fought for took effect in florida last
month it allows people to shorten their
probation term by getting credits by
going to school or working at least 30
hours a week the law also allows people
to check in remotely with their
probation officers mill was inspired to
create the reform alliance with some of
the biggest names in the industry like
jay-z after he was incarcerated for five
months for probation violation fans
demanded his release spurring the free
meek mill movement
and that movement was real meek mill and
entrepreneur michael rubin and
businessman co-chair of the reform
alliance and join us at the table to
discuss we welcome you both this is
really exciting news because it shows
all the hard work you guys have been
doing paid off why is this such a big
deal michael start us off with that you
know for me i didn't understand anything
about the issue then i watched one of my
closest friends go to prison for not
committing a crime i didn't think that
was possible and so once me got out you
didn't think it was possible that you
could go to prison when you didn't do
anything for not commanding yourself no
that's not logical and 25 of the people
that go to prison each year don't commit
a crime but they go to prison and that's
what we need to fix
and so what did you do
as soon as meek got out meek jay-z
myself robert kraft got together we
started the reform alliance for the goal
of how do we get at least a million
people that are on probation and parole
that shouldn't be out of the system
there were four and a half million
people when we started today there's
four million people we're changing we're
fixing the underlying system that's what
you need to do so we're changing laws on
a state-by-state basis so far we've
passed 16 bills 10 states 650 000 people
are on a pathway to get out of prison in
the next five years that shouldn't be
there now by the way there's people that
do belong in prison yeah and you know
this is about getting the people that
shouldn't be in prison out of prison and
how we keep communities safe and also
not waste taxpayer pay our money we're
doing all that so and me this is
personal for you i want people to
understand what you went through can you
briefly describe it i remember once
hearing you say a judge or a prosecutor
with a pen can cause just as much damage
and be just as deadly as someone with a
gun uh when i when i made that statement
i actually made it from sitting in the
curt room watching a judge just
sentenced men and women over simple
violations like weed
marijuana you smoke marijuana on
probation and you know you got sent to a
state prison and you know your kids grew
up without a mother for three years i
just didn't thought i didn't think that
decision was the right decision to be
made out of common sense and then you
know later on in my life it started to
affect my life
me uh i was a lucky one to escape it but
many others like me were unable to
escape it and i was able to be in those
prison with those people face to face
while being successful uh seeing those
people marched for me uh michael stood
up for me we sat down in that visiting
room i told him about my case and
everything how i got in a situation
stood up to all my wrongs or whatever i
felt i done wrong
and expressed him about uh how uh
probation basically almost rejected me
from having a fair shot
at life that the average young black man
should have coming up so you know i
wanted to help and make a change with
that what we're doing now you mentioned
the marijuana violation that's one way
that people can get back into jail when
they're on parole by the term right what
are some of the other ways the sort of
simple violations that can send a person
back to prison uh i could just give you
a shoe like if uh gal you was taking
kids to disney world tomorrow and i
wanted to take my son tomorrow and if i
was on probation uh if i went to disney
world with you and not having like a
sexual crime or anything like that where
you couldn't be around kids if i went to
disney world with you i would be
arrested just for taking my child to
disney world if i didn't contact my
probationer in a certain manner my
probation officer uh you could be
arrested for not being hired for a job
you know you can't time when you would
be hired for a job you know especially
if you have a felony on your record
you could be sent to prison for not
completing school
for not completing the program or just
uh getting a kid up from school i used
to remember voicemails yeah or meek's
probation officer yeah he'd say can i
pick my kid up from school ten minutes
marie lives in new jersey he lived in
pennsylvania she'd say no if you pick
your kid up i will send you to prison
that is crazy in real time on real live
tv i like to express that like where i'm
from in philadelphia it's a lot of
violence for the young black and brown
so my son would attend school in new
jersey he lived in a suburban area
because he
uh
he he grew above poverty through my
music success and he's a smart kid yes a
very a very smart child so you know me
being a rapper traveling in the world
some days i would want to go home and
take my child to school of course it's
kind of almost impossible to make that
decision and call a probation officer so
i would take the risk of taking my child
to school so he could have a feeling of
his father being there so some of those
days earlier you mentioned jobs and the
reform alliance it also puts together uh
job fairs yeah why is this an important
aspect of probation reform
uh i believe it's a important aspect
because if you're out here and being a
a person who contributes to society i
think you should work for your own money
uh you know having a felony is already a
strike against you right uh where you'll
be at a disadvantage so we try to
provide jobs to people who
like myself if i don't know if you guys
call it a second chance i live by god so
i don't live by chances but a second
chance give them a chance to rebuild
their self
and uh you know
td jake said something interesting me
once he told me that he's never seen
somebody who had to go to work the next
day who was robbing somebody
so the importance of having a job and
having a purpose michael i've heard you
say this system is broken that it starts
with the system is broken and that's
really what we want to fundamentally fix
when i saw meat go to prison for not
committing a crime for literally um
popping wheeling on a motorcycle and got
sentenced to two to four years on
probation yeah once once um you know
jay-z and desiree perez and myself work
together to get him out of prison we
also we have to fix the underlying
system you can't fix this one at a time
there's a systemic issue that has there
are millions of people today on
probation that shouldn't be on probation
and for all now by the way there's
millions that are on probation and
parole should be there and they need
help we need to be rebuilt for those who
are doing the right thing though the
system is broken yeah it's not rewarding
their decisions of turning their life
around i know i know we have to go but
can you just tell us something about the
new music that's coming yeah you seem to
be in a really good place in your life
are you yeah i'm in i'm in a real hungry
place in my life so you know we had
september coming up i've been out of uh
uh out the way just working on business
turning my business models up on the
inside before i dive back in and really
so is it dropping soon what are we
talking about yeah uh trey young uh a
lot of the guys the twins a lot of them
have been calling me for my music and
i've been giving it to them to practice
too because streets are waiting you know
i make that war ready dedication dream
chasing music so september should be
about the time here we go
and make new music out at the same time
yeah mike we know business is going well
for you new reforms music you're giving
it to them thank you guys thank you very
much for being here meek mill uh michael
rubin thank you very much